but I do always try to consider the
question of religion which i think is
important because religion shapes
societies and shapes cultures and shapes
values it even in our modern world of
course we see conflicts all around the
world being driven by religious disputes
even even now
and of course through history God the
religious disputes are legion and the
millions of people who have died in the
names of that are it's appalling to to
think about um I was raised Catholic but
have long since stopped practicing I
suppose I be considered a skeptic now
and I just look at religions they really
are you really gonna kill all these
people because a giant invisible guy in
the sky told you to and and you're a
giant invisible guy the sky is different
but but you can't ignore religion in in
fantasy I think because it's it's too
important in the history and the other
thing that of course is is worth
mentioning about religion is in fantasy
is that in most fantasies you have
working magic you have magic that
demonstrably works
which would affect the religious
feelings of many people you know even
when I was a Catholic and going to
catechism and and I was being taught all
these Catholic things you know I would
sort of say a sister what why is it did
all this walking on water and raising
the dead and stuff took place like 2,000
years ago because if it took place now I
would be much more convinced if I could
see it on television you know and and
indeed if I would become the most
religious guy in the world if we could
actually see someone raising the dead or
you know was sending to heaven or or you
know doing any of these things we read
about in the Bible and and other ancient
religious texts and in fantasy that that
does happen here where we are seeing in
in the red God you know for example in
my own books people say well why are the
Brotherhood without banners abandoning
their own religion that they were raised
with the 7 to follow
Thoros of Myr and the red God well it's
partly because they've seen him raised
to dead and not once but several times
that's persuasive
so they're thinking well MIT maybe the
sky has the right of it here